FAISAL ABID: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Or should I say [GERMAN]?
I looked up on Google
Translate how to say that.
Welcome to our talk
on Angular 2.0 Dart,
moving a large scale
application over to Angular.
Who am I?
I am Faisal Abid.
During the day I work at
an AI machine learning
company called Zoom.ai.
We're an automated virtual
assistant for your enterprise,
and we're hopefully going
to be doing some Darts soon.
And during the nights, I run
this crazy app called Ven Chat.
We're a top 100 grossing
applications on Android.
It's powered by a
Dart server, so that's
where I do most of
my Dart development.
KEVIN BIRCH: And my
name is Kevin Birch.
I'm currently the
CTO and co-founder
of a company called The
Overflow based in Toronto.
And you might be curious
about my social handle.
It has nothing to do with
what you found on your chair,
but I am in fact
a drummer as well.
So if the CTO gig doesn't work
out, and you need a drummer,
please give me a shout.
It's good to have a
fallback plan, right?
Just a quick background.
Over 20 plus years
in technology--
I stopped counting when it
got to the plus-- working
through health care
enterprise solutions,
moved into mobile in 2005,
started a company in Toronto
called Silver Birch that
was a mobile game developer.
We had the fortune to be
the crest of the wave.
We took that company public on
a small exchange in Toronto.
But a lot of experience with
these different technologies
over the years,
coming and going.
And recently working with
different startup ventures,
full stack stuff
that I like to do.
So that's where I
met Faisal, working
on a lot of these
kind of things.
We both have a similar mindset
in terms of new opportunities.
First introduced to Dart,
I guess, last summer.
And again, just based on
the experience I've had,
I just really fell in
love with it right away.
I absolutely love
the technology.
And of course, we're
going to be talking
about some use of that
today and some projects
that-- well, one project in
particular that I'm working on.
So it's The Overflow.
And this talk is going
to be a little bit more
along the lines of a
success story, a case study,
using the types of things
we've been talking about
at this summit so far.
And so I'll give
you a little bit
of an outline of what
The Overflow actually
is, just so you understand what
kind of requirements we have,
what the technology is
going to be behind it all.
We are a streaming music
service with a twist.
We are specifically
focused on Christian music.
So you might know
of it as gospel,
you might know of it
as inspirational music.
But think of it as Spotify with
a filtered and curated subset
of the catalog.
So are we competing
with Spotify?
We tend to think not.
We have a massive target
audience, 2.2 billion,
according to 2012 numbers.
Even a small percentage, a
finite percentage of that
makes the subscription
model interesting.
But really, that segment
is very particular, very
cautious about how
they shop for content
online, the browsing
experience, and specifically
how that relates to family.
Wanting their family
to be more of a family
friendly environment.
So that was really the
vision for The Overflow.
And a little bit of
some eye candy here
on the mobile app side.
One of the other
issues that we're
addressing on some of
the other platforms
is things like
Christian and Bollywood
and whatever tend to get lumped
into a single genre, right?
And I don't think-- that's
not really appropriate.
That's frustrating
for these end users,
because Christian is more of a
segment, obviously, of users.
And we're dealing
with, as you can see,
we have genres within
Christian music.
People want to be able to search
for pop and gospel and rock
and different types
of genres within that.
So we think-- we've
already seen since launch
that this is a very well
accepted thought that we had.
And the record labels as
well-- unbelievably supportive
of this, because it allows them
to surface some back catalog
things-- artists, albums that
don't see the light of day
necessarily on other services.
So that was the
intention behind this.
And we did launch in the
US a number of months ago,
and response has been fantastic.
We are seeing an
accelerated growth curve
and planning to launch now
to other territories heading
into 2017.
So really we're talking today
about initial technology
choices that we made.
Why we did that,
and of course now,
why we've ultimately
made the decision
to move to Dart and
Angular 2 to better
support the growth in
our future requirements.
So just a quick
overview of the old
tech-- very small team to start.
This is self-funded,
three people.
I was the only
developer on the team.
So we built a
whole entire stack.
The choices that we made
were just-- of course,
we've grown from there.
But initially, with the proof
of concepts and the baby steps,
it was myself.
Initially the
choices were simply
based on what is going
to be able to get us out
there quickly, prototyping,
quick iterations.
And certainly that
doesn't rule out
Dart or other technologies that
were available at the time.
But it was also a
lot based on-- we
don't want to spend a lot
of time learning new things,
working with what we knew.
For our technology we
chose PHP for our web tools
and Node for our API.
So our web tools were
purely internal facing.
So we didn't have a lot
of internal back and forth
about whether to use it or not.
It was just they were internal
facing administration tools
that we needed to manage our
system, to manage our catalog.
So just as a frame
of reference in terms
of the scope of this thing,
there are three million albums
in our master catalog,
and 28 million songs
that have to be streamed and
downloaded and constantly
managed as new content comes
out from other record labels.
So the administration
tools are significant,
but again, they were
internally facing.
So PHP was chosen for that.
Node was new to me at the time.
I would normally have used
Java back ends traditionally
with servlets,
Tomcat, J2EE stacks.
But again, for the sake of speed
Node seemed absolutely perfect.
I think we had talked
about that at the time.
And so just in
terms of our usage,
it was a lightweight solution,
getting things out there
quickly, quick iterations.
So that's sort of where we
started in terms of our tech.
Why was it a problem?
It met our requirements
at the time,
but we were showing
real signs of success.
It was going in the
direction that we
were hoping it would go.
And so it was really
time, of course,
to move away from proof of
concept baby steps and time
to expand and re-evaluate
our technology platform.
We needed a web client.
So we had only launched
originally with the apps.
It was an app, mobile only play
at first with Android and iOS
native apps.
We had a very simple
architecture initially,
database, API service layer,
and these native apps talking
through that API service layer.
But it was time to expand,
and with a web client
we needed multiple
developers, multiple teams.
We need to obviously-- in order
be even remotely competitive
out there, we need
machine learning,
we need automated
curation of our playlists,
and so on and so forth.
So it was now time to get past
the proof of concept stage,
figure out what was the
best platform for us
to build our solution on.
So I am a fan of
PHP, but I think
in certain situations it really
works well as a quick solution.
But ultimately, I think--
probably a lot of us
would agree-- maybe
not the best solution
for a long term, large
scale platform like this,
needing multiple developers,
multiple teams working
on different parts
of the system,
really separating
presentation, business, logic,
and so on and so forth.
Node-- I would say less of
a problem, certainly great
and could have kept us going.
But as we went through
the evaluation process
of other technologies
available, there
was clearly big
advantages in coming up
with some type of
platform that could
be used across all
layers on the full stack.
And so as we began to
really carefully evaluate
where we should go from
here, my good friend Faisal--
we had lots of long
discussions about this,
and of course, he had some
recommendations for me.
FAISAL ABID: Yeah.
So when Kevin came
to me and said,
all right, Overflow's
growing, and we need scale.
But Node and PHP and
all these technologies
aren't really cutting it for me.
I looked at his code
base, and I said, crazy.
So like Watson and Sherlock,
we went on searching.
And back then, I just
recently became a GD.
But before that,
past year or so,
I was doing a lot
of Dart development.
So I got a real sense
of the power of Dart,
because previously
I ran another chat
app, which was all Node JS.
And I understood the struggles
that you face once you
hit big time with Node.
So I went to Kevin
and I said, all right,
here's what Dart gives you.
Dart gives you
object-oriented programming.
Kevin was like, awesome.
I think he was
playing his drums.
And I then started showing
much more cooler features,
like Observatory.
And I said, look
what you can do.
If you're writing a web app,
you can pull up Observatory,
and you can actually
do lots of profiling
and all this crazy stuff there.
And Kevin was blown away.
And then the magic, I think,
was when I started showing async
and await.
And I said, all
right, so here's what
you would do in Node normally.
And I looked at his
code, and I said, OK.
So you load a trap, you
download music, all that stuff.
Look at that crazy callback.
And it was four levels
of callback hell.
And I said, OK, let me show
you how you do that in Dart.
Which is just four lines, right?
Await, await, and we're good.
And so once that
started happening,
I went through
the other features
like Streams, like
Cascade operators.
And once we got
there, it was perfect.
This was a perfect fit for
Overflow and their scale.
And so what we needed was--
there was a web app currently,
but we needed to
really rewrite that web
app into something much more
scalable, in Dart, obviously.
So we started to
explore technologies.
Back then there was Dart
HTML, there was Polymer,
and there was Angular 2.0,
beta, alpha, whatever it was.
So I discovered Angular.
And technically I
discovered Angular Dart,
because I was an Angular JS
developer back in the day.
I did lots of Scope
apply everywhere.
So I started investigating.
Kevin had worked with Angular
previously before, too.
One thing that I really,
really enjoyed about Angular
was this idea of components,
how everything is a component.
And during my day-- or I used to
do a lot of mobile development.
So writing web apps
like mobile apps
is like coming home for me.
So what I liked a
lot about Angular
was this Component
Lifecycle that they had.
And you can see that it
starts off with ngOnChanges,
OnInit, OnClick.
And then you have a
bunch of other stuff
like AfterContentInit.
So something that we often
hook into is ngAfterViewInit.
So if there is a progress loader
or something like that showing,
we would-- after the content's
Init and after it's viewed,
great.
Hide the loader, load
the data, do whatever.
So this felt a lot like
onResume on Android.
Any Android developers here?
Yes, right.
OnResume or on iOS, it's
like View did show, whatever
that side of the world does.
So then what I also
liked was the idea
of dependency injection.
Dependency injection makes large
scale development a lot easier.
Writing unit tests
and stuff I hate
doing when I'm
writing small apps.
But when you're starting
to write large scale apps,
unit testing is very important.
And so dependency injection
makes everything a lot easier.
So we can just inject
the API service,
have a mock one
later, do a unit test.
And then with the new stuff
that we saw earlier today,
I think that's going to
make a lot of things easy.
So with all that, I said
to Kevin, all right,
let's just build this in
Angular 2, hope for the best,
and that they're going
to go final soon.
And let's just launch this.
KEVIN BIRCH: Yeah.
So it was an easy
sell once I had
a good look at the
components and based
on previous experience.
We had a web data
already in place,
so we weren't in any big rush.
We had an opportunity to
experiment a little bit
with this technology.
But we decided to do it.
I think it was the
best decision ever.
And especially hearing
all the things that
are going on at this conference
and the future of all
these technologies we're using--
very, very excited about this.
Again, we're keeping it a
little bit high level here, just
to give you a sense-- there's
a lot of technical discussions
going on about what's
happening under the covers,
but I'll just
relate some visuals
to what is happening in the
Dart and the Angular 2 world.
So this is a first
iteration of the web client.
And it's fully expanded.
It's a little busy,
because we wanted to show
some extra components for you.
On the right side, we
have a search panel
that comes in and out.
That's a persistent search.
You can always come back to that
and hit another search result
at any time.
It's a single page application.
So we have some of these kind
of flexible options here.
The player as well down below
is a component, the navigation,
of course, the header.
And then the central
area is our content area.
And even within that, of course,
lots of sub components, album
widgets, playlist widgets.
So this is what the user sees,
but of course, on the back end
or on the code side of things,
what the developers see
would look something like this.
Simplifying some things, just
to give you a sense of it,
but this is the tag structure
underneath our high level app
component.
So you can see some familiar
tags, or at least ones
that would relate to
the previous slide--
header, navigation.
The interesting thing
about our content area
would be that this is the router
outlet, meaning any navigation
that we do throughout the site,
through the navigation panel,
or other links is targeting
this particular area.
So that's the big
content area I showed you
on the previous slide.
There's some other
UI things here
that I didn't show
you, cues and such,
but you understand the point.
And obviously, the
awesome thing here
is that each tag has its own
corresponding self-contained
code component-- HTML,
styles, business logic,
and sub components as well.
Lots of things, as we've
already been through a fair bit
over today.
And then just to give you
a little sample of what
the code would look like and
some of the things Faisal
was talking about-- we have an
API service class that we've
labeled as injectable.
Anything within the system
that needs to, of course,
bring data in from
the backend, we
inject this component into it.
And then underneath, we see a
sample of what this home page
component looks like.
Again, that's not
the entire wrapper.
That would be the app component.
But the home page component
is the content area,
like we have a playlist
component, an album component
to view those details.
So again, defining
a selector, that's
the router outlet I mentioned.
The content is being pushed
to that particular selector.
We have an HTML
file that defines
the template, the layout,
the framework of the page.
And then directives,
bringing in other components
like-- I have removed
a few things here,
but the key ones would
be our router link
component and our
loader component,
which allow us to
navigate across the app.
And the loader component,
as Faisal mentioned,
is just a little UI
to indicate loading
as things are coming
in from the back end
and as the page is rendering.
And then the API service
is also referenced
as an injectable object.
So this particular
class is conforming
to part of the life-- one
of the lifecycle methods
after viewing it.
It simply means that
we need to implement
this ngAfterViewInit
method, which
is called after the view is
fully loaded and initialized.
Which in this
scaled down example
is just showing that we're
removing the loader component.
Getting rid of that loader
UI and displaying the content
of the page in all its glory.
So everything was really,
really, super smooth and fast.
There's been a lot of
talk about productivity.
talk about clean code.
For us, it was a very, very
positive experience just doing
this as an experiment.
And we started with beta
12, so a few months back.
So we've had a little
bit of refactoring to do
as things have changed there.
But again, everything
just works,
and I'm just super happy
that it is 100% Dart.
Except, of course, for
the cases where we do
use JavaScript interop, which
I won't get into detail.
That's been talked about
brilliantly by Jacob earlier.
But we do use
JavaScript interop.
There are things like analytics
libraries, customer support
libraries, even
some audio players
that we tie into--
audio player widgets
that we tie into
from time to time.
But JavaScript interop
allows us to do that,
and this is just
a stock example.
This isn't our code.
But we've seen that already.
So it's obviously important
talk about-- how did this help?
So after the web client was
really a success in our minds,
we thought, OK, we're going
to do this everywhere.
And so we immediately went
and converted the API layer
to Dart.
It was very quick and painless.
That is in production now.
It's been in production for
quite a while, actually.
And we're converting the admin
tools, not as much of a rush,
but we're converting
that as well.
Just because they're
internal we're
doing that slowly
as time allows.
But the big thing
for us really is
the lack of context
switching now
between different technologies.
We're able to-- we
don't have to keep
track of different technologies
moving at different paces.
That was discussed earlier.
And that is absolutely true.
And our development
teams can more easily
operate between layers as
we get a consistent platform
across API admin tools.
And of course,
looking to the future
for mobile-- very
excited about tomorrow's
talks about Flutter and such.
The other big jump in
productivity for us
was being able to really
extract a common Dart library.
We pulled out all
our model code.
We pulled out, of
course, API access
stuff that some of those
components would need.
Utility methods into
a shared library
that's now able to
be used across all
of these different
layers in our system.
It's really, really great.
And I do personally believe
that the move to Dart,
away from JavaScript
and PHP, has just
forced a cleaner
and more structured
code and architecture.
Also, it has been
discussed-- I was watching
Lars and Casper's Intro
to Dart video from 2012
on the plane over here.
And that's touched
on brilliantly
in terms of why Dart was
created and its comparisons
with JavaScript.
So you can talk about that.
FAISAL ABID: So we
get asked often,
whenever we tell our
story to other developers
is, well why didn't you use
Angular 2 JavaScript or Angular
2 TypeScript?
And really it's
not about Angular.
It's really about the language
that's powering Angular.
For me, personally, Dart is
putting Angular on steroids.
Angular as it is is a
great, great framework.
It was great in 1.5, and
that's why it got this far.
But Dart really pumps
up the productivity.
And when you're using
something-- at least what
I've personally
found, my opinion.
When you use something like
JavaScript, Angular JavaScript,
with a bunch of power and
all these crazy plugins
that you have there,
all these technologies
are moving at different rates.
It's really hard to
keep track of that.
What I like about using
Angular Dart is just
it's one solid technology
that I can just develop on.
When it updates, it updates.
That's great for me.
So it comes back to Dart
being great-- I mean,
Angular is great, but it comes
back to Dart being amazing.
So the language is
stable, obviously.
Observatory, for example,
as I was talking before,
this stuff is great
when you're developing.
When you're actually developing
a web application, when
I see this-- I look
at this all the time,
because this is amazing.
And then you have really
nice stuff like Streams.
Using all this when you're
writing your Angular app
is crazy.
This is just mind
blowing to me coming
from a mobile background,
even doing cold fusion back
in the day.
And then using
stuff like-- here's
another thing that
I personally like
about Dart, which is
what makes Angular great,
is if you're trying to use
something like async in Node
or on the web, you have
to use the async package,
and you have to
chain all this up.
Dart is batteries included.
We've heard this
over and over again.
It comes with a great
async framework.
So I can just do Future.wait,
pass in my methods,
and it just waits for them.
And then the other thing is this
idea of being object-oriented.
I love it.
That's because it makes
stuff like building
singletons really, really easy.
When you're writing web
applications in general,
having this flexibility,
having this power
makes it a cohesive
experience where
I don't have to worry about,
oh, can I do this on the web?
No, but I can just
do it with Dart.
And then lastly, just
other simple features
that I think make Angular
great because of Dart
is stuff like names
of parameters.
Tons of times I don't
want to method overload
a bunch of stuff.
I can just do name parameters.
It gets the job done.
So overall, this is why I
feel Angular 2 Dart is great.
It's because of Dart.
It's because Dart is there.
And then what's nice about Dart
is, like Kevin was mentioning,
once we have this code base, we
can share it across the stack.
So as you saw earlier
in the screenshots,
Kevin showed some mobile apps.
The idea eventually
is once we investigate
Flutter more is to move
all this over to Flutter.
We save-- less development time.
And then all this
code that we're
using on Angular, something
like a singleton class,
we can use it on Flutter.
We can use it on the
web as long as it's
platform independent, whatever.
So that's one of the
productivity gains
that you get by using Dart.
And having Angular
is essentially
putting it on steroids.
KEVIN BIRCH: Yeah.
So hopefully that
was interesting
as a real world case
study, external--
I guess-- real world case
study in terms of the things
we're talking about.
We are extremely happy with
our decision to move to Dart.
Absolutely committed to using
it inside of The Overflow
and myself to
other projects that
might come up in the future.
Again, we've been able to move
things forward very quickly.
We've seen big bumps
in productivity.
And we're firing
on all cylinders.
We just have had zero
down time on the APIs.
The web's been solid, and
it's only first release.
There's a lot more to do there.
But looking very much forward to
next steps and the things we're
taking away from
this conference.
I just want to go
home and start coding.
But thank you very
much for your time.
And if there are any questions
or any comments you have,
we'd love to meet you and
hear about those later.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]